bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you
subscribe to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i am
here with only one of the two [ __ ]
fosters twins i don't know where the
other one is but duncan is here thank
you so much for doing this man
thanks pop thanks for having me back of
course uh
all right last time we talked things
were getting hot
they got real real hot though uh i feel
like you guys saw the future
you guys were way ahead of the curve uh
what has happened just give us like a
state of the union of the nft market
uh from your perspective where are we
and what's happened so far
so honestly i think i think we're kind
of in the the first phase where people
are like really realizing the potential
and from us from from our perspective
it's been completely insane
this that i always like to give about
this is november 2020 last year
we just we had a million dollars in
monthly volume for the first time
and we were thrilled because that was
already 20x what we had done five six
months ago
and we were happy we were like okay we
just grew 20 x in five or six months
you know things are moving along it's a
bit hectic a bit crazy but like
things are growing steadily and then
last month in march 2021 we did 140
million
so if you told me back in november that
we'd you know go on to
do 140 times our volumes in the next
five six months
i just like would not have believed you
and uh
yeah it's been like it's been completely
completely insane for us and everyone in
the nft space
i i always thought it was going to
happen i did not think it was going to
happen this like quickly or suddenly
but i guess that's just like that always
happens with with new technologies so
absolutely so when you start to think
about
um kind of the nft market uh
you have a key piece of infrastructure
right in nifty gateway
uh there's a bunch more infrastructure
that's popped up uh how do you think
about how you guys are differentiated
from everybody else
obviously you know from the beginning
our our perspective was always we're
going to make
nfts as easy to access as possible you
know we we want to
build nfts on top of a truly
decentralized network like ethereum
but we want to make them as easy for
people to buy as it is buying something
on amazon
and i you know that honestly when you
look back at the history of crypto
it's kind of amazing how many businesses
are are started with that same intent
because crypto's this incredible
technology that that people just have a
difficult time accessing
it's just really you know hard to use
for the average person
i mean this is like i was this is the
same thing that motivated coinbase they
were they were basically said like you
know crypto's gonna be huge but
you know regular people need an easy way
to access it so honestly
that that's always been our our drive
and our motivation making
nfts built on ethereum the truly
decentralized network making those
as simple to access as possible um
and i really think that that's been like
that's been enormous in our
success so far because you know most of
the
most of the people that we talk to most
of the people that are are collecting
nfts on nifty gateway
um you know they they're not ready to
go with the full like on-chain
experience external wallet they control
they need like a simpler way to access
it and i really think that's been just
like a huge part of our success
yeah so when you talk about early access
uh or easier access not necessarily but
uh easier access what are some of the
things specifically that you guys have
done that you think has kind of
manifested that access yeah it's a great
question
we i mean we really had to iterate
towards this um the first thing that we
did was just let people buy nfts with a
credit card
and that was back in in 2019 that we we
launched that and we worked with
cryptokitties and axe infiniti
from there we decided you know we had to
take it a step further
which meant we had to build a system
where you could sign up and get started
collecting nfts without ever onboarding
into cryptocurrency you know without
signing up for an external wallet
just signing up with an email address
and password
um and so that's really the that's
really what we've reached now
that that's what i think is so important
to nifty gateway's success is that
if you want to access nfts all you have
to do is sign up with a username and
password
throw in your credit card and then you
can start collecting
um it really makes the experience
something that anyone can understand
and i think that's you know that as
we've seen with crypto before
it's really important to have that that
easy accessible layer to
to make something mainstream and
honestly i don't think that we would
have anywhere near the same amount of
traction that we do today
if we hadn't focused so hard on that
that core piece of user experience
yeah and then one of the other things
that you've done is uh you've got this
curation approach right so you one made
it easy to access but then you've also
taken a very heavy
curation some people would argue right
like uh a critic would say
uh oh that goes against everything in
the open ethos of crypto right kind of
just build the platform let whoever
wants to transact there
uh but i know that this has been really
crucial to your success and so
how do you think about uh curation uh
why did you choose to do that and then
what's kind of been the benefit of it
yeah so we when we back when we first
started
most of the nft players were sort of
taking what we
say is like the classic tech approach or
even like the classic crypto approach
which basically is like we're just going
to build a platform
and then we're going to try and convince
you to sign up for it and then you use
it you don't use it like we don't really
care we're hands off after you sign up
that's sort of like the traditional like
everyone wants to be a platform because
they think it's
the easiest like airbnb you just sit in
the middle people sign up they rent
houses
you take money and yeah that seems like
the easiest
and that's the approach everyone was
taking in the nft space
um what we what we thought about was
okay
if you look in the art and collectibles
world you you kind of don't see that
like people are almost explicitly not a
platform and instead it's much more of
like okay we're going to go out and
and select the best artwork we have a
ton of knowledge in the space so we're
going to curate artists who
we think are promising and then because
we curated them
their their reputations will grow like
we're basically
basically what art galleries do is they
lend their brand to the artists that
they present
and we thought okay nfts nfcs are the
future of art and collectibles it's
likely that we'll see that same dynamic
replicate itself in the nft space um
there were already curated platforms
back then platforms where you had to
apply
and get in but we took it a step further
and we said okay we're gonna
every single release that we do on the
primary market we're gonna curate
and every single release we do we're
gonna talk one-on-one with the artists
we're gonna
help them figure out their pricing help
them figure out their quantity like
help them monitor the the health of
their market and really like be a true
partner to them that was always our
vision that we wanted to be a true
partner to the artists that we
we partnered with and then i i think
that that has also been really
really important um you know nifty
gateway
the the artists on nifty gateway are the
highest earning on average out of all
the other
all of all the nft platforms because we
you know we spend so much effort
partnering with them and
and really trying to help them grow
their careers and help them monitor the
the health of their market um
and so yeah i think that approach has
also been enormous for our
for our platform and you know it's part
of the reason that you know
we have all the traction that we did and
i think it sort of came from going
against the grain and saying okay
everybody wants to be a platform but
maybe that's not the right approach here
because maybe this market will work
differently
yeah and so when you start to think
about uh how that market has been
uh receiving this it seems like uh one
not only did they say nifty is
quote unquote the winner right in terms
of this curation type of approach but
it's also brought a very different type
of artist to the table as well
um you know a lot of the digital artists
who have been on
multiple platforms they have different
styles they have different
approaches but they fall under what i
would call a digital artist bucket right
whether it's traditional artists who are
becoming digital artists or the digital
artist
it seems like you guys have really found
a niche not only with a digital artist
but also with people who kind of come
out from outside of that world and so
was that a
intended strategy or did that just kind
of naturally happen
yeah it was an intended strategy from
you know from the beginning we were
always trying to figure out ways to get
more people
into nfts and into the world of nfts and
we thought one of the best ways to do
that was to
go out find artists who had a fan base
outside of the nft space
enlist them to make work on the platform
and then the artist would introduce
their audience
to nfts just by the fact that they were
releasing work on the platform
i i think that honestly it was kind of
slow going at first it's hard to explain
what an nft is but you know by the time
an
artist does their their second or third
release you really start to see their
people who are fans of their physical
artwork getting into their nfts
and honestly we've seen some go the
other direction where people who are
collecting nfts on nifty gateway start
buying the physical
artwork of nifty gateway artists artists
that they found through nifty gateway
so it's really like a pretty powerful
effect and
i think it was a really important step
in nfts
um evolving and you know becoming a more
becoming a more like well-known and
mainstream
phenomenon which is you know artists who
are a lot of artists are
multi-disciplinary like
you know some of the best like you know
picasso sculptures are some of his most
famous as well
as as well as his paintings so it makes
sense that a lot of them are
you know would be creating a digital and
uh it's certainly cool
it's really cool to see them creating on
nifty gateway for sure
talk a little bit about the impact on
some of these artists right um everyone
knows the story of let's say philosophy
is 17 years old
ends up uh making enough money to not
only leave their home but ends up
actually building an entire living out
of it right
uh people same thing has now made
millions and millions of dollars but
i think outside of some of those big
stories there's also seem to be a pretty
positive impact on every artist who
starts to do this and so what are either
some of your favorite stories
or just some of your takeaways as you've
seen artists enter in and have an impact
on their careers
yeah honestly i mean i think the foolish
story is my favorite story
um where you know he could move out and
buy a house he's so young and
so talented and like he's really able to
to make a living doing what he loves
at this young age um
uh yeah we we basically have seen i mean
the the stories are too
are almost too numerous like repeat here
we we have a slack channel called feels
good where
we just post like you know happy tweets
from artists or artists being like thank
you so much
i think one actually that really touched
me was from matt gondeck
he uh he did a sale on nifty gateway
i can't remember his a few months ago
and he grossed over 1.8 million in sales
and i think what he tweeted was um my
my parents my dad had a stroke last year
and they need to move down south
to like be in a sunnier climate you guys
just bought them a house like thank you
so much nifty gateway family
that was like a really powerful i mean
that that
to see like nifty gateway changing an
artist's life like that and
you know helping him support his dad who
was like sick that yeah that was pretty
amazing
um i i think honestly yeah it's really
my favorite part of the job and like
most nifty gateway employees it's
i think it's like their favorite part of
the job to just seeing an artist like
have their life changed like that
yeah you guys have multiple ways that
ours can do a drop um maybe let's start
just at a high level with like what
makes a successful drop
from your experience honestly
you know what i what i try and emphasize
to artists i think we're in a tricky
moment right now where
there's this huge group this huge new
influx of interest in the nft wave and
it seems like you can't even
open twitter these days without seeing
nft written somewhere
but as we've seen before you know it can
be
it can sort of generate unhealthy
dynamics when things grow too quickly
and you know you can sort of get away
from the from the things that made
things work well in the first place
so what i try to emphasize the artist is
that your secondary market sales are
are like you know probably the most the
most important thing for you
and you know you really should think
about your career on a long term basis
as an artist you should really be
thinking about this on like a five-year
10-year
basis and trying to design your your
your drops to reflect that and really
less is more when you're when you're
releasing on the primary market
the most successful artists that i've
seen they've done a really good job
building demand um alongside supply
and then you know eventually by the time
of their third or fourth release
they're really really popular they have
a great collector base they're they're
really well known on the platform
and then they can do like a large
release and you know gross a really high
amount
but but yeah really what i would say is
like um
come in make sure you're thinking about
this as a long-term project make sure
you're thinking about nfts for
five years 10 years not just when it
comes the work itself is obviously
incredibly important but
there's a lot of strategy to you know
the release structure as well
um and yeah the long term is like is far
more important than the short term
i think that's the most important thing
for any artist to remember especially an
artist just getting started
for sure uh and you have multiple ways
that somebody can sell so you can do
kind of a one-of-one
auction you can do a direct sale you can
do these like uh
open uh series talk through um
kind of the pros and cons of each one or
kind of how you guide
artists to think through uh which type
of sale mechanic they should use on a
specific drop
absolutely um the one of one obviously
is the most scarce
sale dynamic you can do the the pros of
that are
it keeps your supply really low
um you know it's a great way to just get
started uh
the cons are you know only a very few
only a very small
number of people can afford one-of-ones
um so
you know they tend to be much higher in
price which means like your collector
base is limited
and honestly i think one of the coolest
parts about nfts is they're sort of
democratizing art
like fine art is very inaccessible for
most people nfts are way more accessible
so one of ones are are awesome but you
know
you do have to be really rich to afford
them um
then the other the other thing that
artists can do is limited edition sizes
so
additions they can pick any addition
size they want and then they can either
release them up for
auction or they can do a price honestly
i think a really strong way to enter the
space is
to do an addition of 100 and price it
really low and then
the collectors who win you know who get
to buy that piece they have
a great premium where that piece can
trade up because it was originally
priced
low um so yeah that's the second release
format you can
you can fix an addition size and you can
fix it at whatever size you want
you could fix it at 10 you could fix it
at 100.
usually 100 is sort of the high limit
but we have had some people who fix
their edition sizes at 500
and then you can either release it as a
as an auction where people place bids on
it
or you can just do a drawing where you
say i'm going to sell these for 10
each and then it's random who gets
selected to buy the pieces
and then yeah the third the third main
type is the open edition
the open edition is where you set a
price and you say anyone can
come buy this piece for a period of time
maybe five minutes maybe 10 minutes
and then the addition size is determined
by how many are sold
so the the key advantage of open
editions are
they do make your work far more
accessible to to regular people
you can set a price where you know
people will be able to afford it with
all the other release formats
you know some people may get outbid and
they won't be able to afford it
or maybe they'll get unlucky and they'll
lose the drawing but with an open
edition
you know you can guarantee that people
who follow you will be able to collect
your work
um you know open editions are also the
the freest
release format you know that that means
that people a bunch of people could buy
your work
and maybe they're just speculating on it
maybe they don't really want to own it
so they sell it for a loss a week later
and that makes you look bad as an artist
so i think open editions are they they
can also be one of the scariest release
formats to do
because you're basically you're letting
anyone do whatever you want
with with your artwork at least with an
auction you know the person buying it
is the person who wants to own it the
most so their intentions are probably
pure but uh yeah those are those are
basically like the
the main release formats that we do for
sure
and so what are people doing with the
nfts they're buying right there's all
these artists and i think that part of
the beauty of nfts and the
infrastructure is uh
really that um there's been this
democratization of
uh the ability to sell right and get
your art and digitize it and
do all that but there's obviously in the
marketplace there's buyers on the other
side so what exactly are people buying
is it speculation on price and they're
looking at it as an investment are they
displaying it somewhere just what do you
see them doing yeah i
honestly i think especially with a huge
run up people really tend to
they tend to like look at nft collectors
as a monolith and they tend to say like
oh this is all just speculation
or you know this is just everybody doing
everything different collectors have
different
intents like you know that like people
buy nfts for a lot of different reasons
and this is what i always try and
emphasize to people like there's not
just one reason that people buy nfts
it's the same way with physical art
there's really like a lot of
a lot of different reasons that people
buy nfts
personally i my favorite thing to do
with them is is display them in the
screens that i
have in my house and i love to show them
off when people come over
it used to be a bit more challenging
because i had in order to show them off
i had to first explain what an nft was
and then explain that i was showing off
in nfte but now
like so many more people are familiar
with them i actually had a task rabbit
come over to my house the other day
and she walked in and she saw my screen
and she's like oh those are nfts and i
was like oh my god
this is going mainstream i can't believe
it but uh yeah
personally that's my favorite thing to
do is show them off the same way that
people would show off physical art
i i honestly think that everybody exists
on sort of an
investor collector spectrum in the nft
world
which is exactly what you see in the the
fine art world as well
where some people are doing it mostly to
collect um some people are doing it
mostly to invest
and then there's like there's really
just like a mix of of in between
but i don't think almost everyone who's
buying nfts like has some sort of
emotional attachment to them
and and the crazy part is even the
people who do it mostly as an investment
when they buy art
they talk about how like sad they feel
whenever they sell a piece and this like
feeling of like
you're like damn i can't believe i let
that go even if you're selling it for
way more than you bought it for it it
really is like a sad experience to
to sell a work of your art so yeah i i
think um
oh and the other thing that i should
mention is that people are building
these like beautiful museums
in digital worlds in the metaverses and
people are just like showing off their
nfc you know like tweeting about an nfc
you bought is honestly a pretty good way
to show it off
so yeah it i really do think that people
tend to view nft collectors as a
monolith
but the nf2 collectors are like a large
group of people who really do it for
a variety of different reasons um some
of them like to collect
some of them do like are more into
speculation and do just view it as sort
of like an
asset to be flipped but really there's
like a wide variety
and so when you start thinking about um
where we've gotten to in this market you
saw this
much much earlier uh i'm guessing that
you probably didn't think it was going
to happen
this soon right but are we still in the
early days
is this something that feels like no you
know that we're going to have this like
long
uh winter just how do you think about
market dynamics and timing and you know
for many people they're just now
discovering nfts and they're just now
exploring about them
uh does that suggest that there's still
kind of a really long runway and ten
years from now it's gonna be much bigger
than it is today or just how do you
think about it
yeah absolutely and and actually you
know a lot of people don't realize this
but like there was an nft winter before
and that's really when i got into it i
mean the first nft
the first nft project that really got
sort of major traction
or major attention was cryptokitties and
that you know that got written about it
was in like all the major media outlets
it was all over twitter
it was famous for sort of crashing the
network the ethereum network
but then immediately after that i mean
cryptokitties said usage plummeted
there are all these cryptokitties
copycat apps that came up and most of
them just folded
they're they're a few like big nft
companies that raise venture money
and you know i think most of those
companies ended up just
like shutting down the doors and
returning the money that's when i
started nifty gateway there there was
already like an nft winter that we saw
before
and what i like to emphasize is that
nifty gateway has had
i mean we've had days where we we did
close to as much volume as cryptokitties
did in
its entire lifetime and an nba top shot
has had days i think where they've
exceeded cryptokitty's lifetime volume
so like yeah there was this before we
saw this dynamic in nfcs where there's
this huge run-up in interest
um there was this sort of winter long
period but now here we are a few years
later
we're literally a thousand times larger
than the peak was back then that that's
just how these go i mean like this is
it's really not too dissimilar from
crypto really my
yeah i my view on this is like uh
what what happened in the winter time
was the winter it sounded so dramatic
but
what happened in the nft winter is that
the people came in coming in like really
formed strong
attachments to the nfts that they were
buying and they really started to like
love them for the art's sake or
or for the collectible state and that
formed like the the solid foundation of
a healthy market
and so that's really what we're trying
to focus on at nifty gateway
we're really trying to do more to
educate educate people and tell them
like hey
you're best off buying nfts that you
really love and that you're really proud
of
because we think that's one sort of like
the solid bedrock of a
strong collector community yeah
talk to me about digital museums we
talked a little bit about what people do
with them
uh i keep hearing people talking about
digital museums virtual world
uh kind of the metaverse all the stuff
what are you thinking there have you
spent any time looking at digital
museums and uh do you think it's
interesting or not
yeah i i mean i've spent a little time
looking at the museum of crypto art
um which is insomnium space i think it's
one of the most incredible
nft collections um i still don't have a
vr headset so i haven't been able to
experience it
in all of its glory but uh yeah i do
think it's a really fascinating
i mean it's really like a cool way to
show off nfts and you can do so much
more in a
virtual space than you can in a physical
space
so yeah it's not an area where i've
spent a ton of time but
it seems to be like a great use case of
nfts
and honestly i mean that's that's what i
think the
the best thing to do with art is right
like you should put it in a museum
um and let people admire it i actually
think i really think that we need to
open up a physical nft museum
because here's the thing like nft so we
we've got all the young people like we
have all the people who are like
on social media you know like imagine
how many people would come visit an nft
museum like there's so many
there these artists have so many fans
like the you know we we have a lot of
followers
like so so many people are so into this
that we could drive so many people
to a physical museum and honestly like
you know i think like
i think the the art that we sell is just
like way more exciting
and like five seven years from now if
you like put us right up next to the
the mobile or the met i'd imagine like
most people in the next generation would
be like no i want to go check out the
nfts like i don't want to see
the boring old like modern art like i
want to see the like new exciting stuff
so i think we need a physical museum to
compete with all the physical art
museums
i i tend to think that you're probably
right on that one um
when you start thinking about uh
physical uh i know that
you've got some physical displays uh
you're actually probably the first
person who ever told me about this a
year ago or so
uh what are you thinking there have you
seen any interesting innovations in the
physical
nft displays um or what do you think
people should be building if they're
interested in that
i i tell whoever i whoever i meet that
this is like a billion dollar company
waiting to be started
um so maybe i shouldn't share i'll share
my plans on the podcast because like
i'm too busy i would never be able to
start this but yeah i think there's like
an
amazing nft display company out there
waiting to be started
i actually think the way that it should
be approached every whenever anyone
thinks about an nft company the first
thing that they think about is hardware
they're like okay i need to go out and
build a hardware device and then sell it
to people
to display their nfts but i actually
think that's wrong i mean building
hardware is
is enormously difficult like very
difficult to get right
you're going to deal with all these
issues instead the way to start it would
be as a services company
and instead what you do is all the
people you know like
we have people we're talking to that are
trying to do nft art shows
as in order to do an nfc art show you
have to figure out a way to display the
nft or say you're starting a hotel and
you want to show up your nfts
you need a good solution someone who can
just come in and be like
yes we are the experts in displaying
nfcs we'll get everything set up for you
just pay us a flat fee
i think this would be the this is the
company to start
you you start like a services company
that rents out the screens
charges people a monthly fee and then
make sure that the screens work 100 of
the time
make sure that the nfc displays are are
perfect and beautiful
that's how you could gain a foothold and
then from there you would basically own
all the demand you would know everyone
trying to build
nft displays and then you could start
selling them physical devices
and the thing is like people really
underestimate this market i mean people
there are so many art museums around the
world there are so many like corporate
offices there are so many hotels
displaying physical art is a much bigger
industry than people realize
so i actually think that this is sort of
like a a great company sitting there
waiting to be started if you're
listening to this podcast
feel free to take my idea and use it
just make sure that you call me so that
we can integrate with nifty gateway
because this is really what we want we
want someone to go out and like build a
great display solution
so that we can sell it to our customers
before you call
uh anyone at nifty gateway make sure you
call me
so that i can invest and then we'll go
to nifty gateway and then we'll have a
a great solution no problem um all right
so when you
look at uh the last 12 months or so
what's been the most surprising thing
for you through this
uh this chaos oh boy um
honestly the yeah the i would say the
most surprising thing is
is basically like the the level of like
famous people that we
really like talk to or that just like
want to call us now
um i i really was not seeing that coming
when we first started nifty gateway it
was like
we very much had to go out and like
pound the pavement in order to get
people to sign up and use the platform
and now the inbound requests we get are
like just ridiculous
you know um and the people that we're
releasing content with
i i frankly would never i like those
were the people on our dream list
you know like six seven months ago we
were like oh my god maybe
one day we could get this person
watching nfts and now they're like
blowing up our phone being like hey can
i launch you
it's it's just so it's a really crazy
experience to go through
who's the most famous person that you've
been on the phone with you've just been
like oh my god i cannot believe this is
happening right now
it was just surreal
i so i don't want to say because the
their project is still a
surprise but um it yeah
i i don't want to like i just all right
who's somebody you can say
i mean honestly uh steve aoki
calvin harris like those were zed these
were all the dj's who i like
listened to in college and everyone like
their music was like incredibly popular
the other day zed retweeted me
i was like holy crap i can't like this
is insane you know if you told me this
like five six years ago
when we were just like listening to zed
yeah and actually yeah i
i do think that the music djs is also
like the dj nfts are another interesting
thing worth
worth talking about if you want to go
into that yeah
why do you think those are interesting
well the we we basically had this phase
where like
three loud or blah you know
still not sure which which it which
a great friend he's like a real like i
love the guy he's a real innovator
um and he really saw this he was another
person who i think like saw this whole
thing happening
before everyone else um so like
yeah he he started it all and he was the
first dj to really like
launch nfts and now a lot more djs are
getting into it
and i actually think it's really
interesting for the art personally
like i think djs can really make
fantastic art that they've never been
able to make before
but a lot of a lot of the way their
collection's perceived is they're just
sort of perceived as celebrities
and people are like oh no there's this
celebrity coming in and like making nfts
and they kind of think like oh it's a
cash grab but really i
i think like again like these musicians
musicians are artists
you know they're not they're celebrities
yes but like they're artists first
and like the stuff that they're creating
in the nft space like genuinely has a
lot of artistic value i think
um so i think that this is one of the
the most underrated
like aspects or like one of the most
underrated
nft categories is like music nfts so
many people are just seeing them as
celebrities but
really they're artists who like know how
to artistically innovate and like know
how to build
like they really understand the dynamics
of nfts pretty well
so i i think that they're sort of like a
good group to keep
keep eyes on for sure and so when you
think about
uh the difference between a musician and
a digital artist like to me
they're just creatives right they're
just creating uh there
actually isn't that big of a difference
it sounds like especially in this new
format
yeah so i we've we've kind of struggled
here right because
you know it used to be it used to be
like the only people coming into nfts
were just like authentically interested
in the medium but now it's become this
big thing it's all anyone talks about
now
in the community there's like people are
anxious they're like we don't want
celebrities coming in and doing a cash
grab
we want to maintain the authenticity of
the community so that's like a new
element that people
like we didn't have to deal with that
five or six months ago because the only
reason people were
into nfc is because they like
authentically found it interesting
now people are thinking about like hey
how do i sort through who's an authentic
creator
who's just trying to like who's just a
celebrity trying to monetize their brand
and i actually think a lot of musicians
have like gotten caught up in this
because yeah musicians are artists
they're not just celebrities trying to
monetize their brand they're artists
creating in this
exciting new medium but a lot of them
have sort of been like
mislabeled as as just celebrities so
yeah i think that's definitely like i
think there's sort of an underestimated
category of nft creators right now
talk to me about the response from the
traditional market uh we've obviously
seen
uh christie's do the auction with people
uh sotheby's i think is doing an auction
uh with pack and uh it just seems like
it just finished today actually it was
on if you gave it
okay and and so talk to me a little bit
just about like what what do you see
from that uh traditional market
look i i honestly think it's great that
they're getting in i think it's huge
validation
of the nft space that christie's and
sotheby's are selling nfts
um you know it really shows that this
this thing is here to stay
and it's not just a fad and you know
where it's like
getting recognition from some of the
largest players in the art world
you know i i think um it in some ways
like
the nft platforms right now are they're
very much internet native businesses
you know they're they're very different
than christie's and sotheby's christians
and sotheby's are auction houses that
have moved online slowly and steadily
but they're not really businesses born
of the internet whereas the nft
platforms are
they are businesses born of the internet
and so they're
you know the stuff that we do on nifty
gateways
is pretty different from the stuff that
sotheby's and christie's do like i
almost think it's
it's so different that i don't even know
if i would consider us in the same
category
because like you know nifty gateway is
all about creators collecting
connecting to their fans like artists
you know doing all sorts of interesting
releases
an artist doing surprise releases and
saying like hey if you
if you've collected three pieces of mind
like i'll give you an extra reward
it's a sort of like living breathing
like very dynamic experience
whereas christie's and sotheby's are you
know
they're they're just like yeah they're
just like normal auction houses where
you put up
stuff for sale so i really do think they
are sort of
categorically different businesses um
and so yeah we don't really think about
them as competitors we think it's
awesome that they're getting into the
space
what are you most excited about moving
forward more artists
is there a specific milestone that
you're like waiting for you're like this
will be another inflection
point just when you look forward what do
you get excited about oh boy i mean this
will be a boring answer but i'm most
excited about
hiring more engineers at nifty gateway
and uh making the platform work
extraordinarily well the the thing about
like the growth we experienced is
uh it just really broke our it broke our
system
which in retrospect i kind of think that
was inevitable like i
i don't know if we could have managed it
in a better way you know because we were
just
we did not expect the the growth that
happened like we were just like not
prepared for that to happen so quickly
so we really ended up in a place where
like way more stuff was broken than
should have been
you know our system some of the code
that we have is like still written by
griffin and i you know
so what i'm most excited about is just
like you know
robustness engineering excellence
growing the team and really
making nifty gateway like a high quality
like truly mature
company um which is kind of a boring
answer but
you know i guess that's like i really
think that's like the
the key to to success you know what what
type of engineers do you need
we need back-end engineers our back-end
is written in python and django
front end our front end is written in
react um and then specifically we're
looking for people who have experience
dealing with
botting and fraud issues um so
yeah all those categories and then we're
also looking for product people as well
so if you're a product manager
um you can shoot me an email at dunkin
niftygateway.com or just go on our
careers page and apply
and yeah that's a i really think that's
the number one thing we need to push the
company forward right now
kind of a lame answer you know i should
be saying like some huge no
you launch or like yeah it's the truth
right if
that's what you need help with and
that's what helps uh build the company
and the product then that's exactly what
you should be saying
you know i honestly um
it when i first started nifty gateway
like you don't really think about
like a startup as just being a hey let's
go ahead and like
recruit as many talented people like you
see the way startups succeed
it's like oh they built the best product
but so now i think so much of it is just
like oh they got a team that like
really made something that worked
exceptionally well and it works like 100
of the time and so people could rely on
it that's the way i think about startups
now
for sure to me about gemiini before i
let you go
uh obviously cameron and tyler bought
nifty gateway
um and you guys have been integrated
into a lot of what uh what they do
uh one obviously they should get kudos
for uh seeing a lot of this similar to
how
you and your brother did kind of coming
but talk a little bit just about how
they've played a role in this uh good or
bad and kind of how you think about
uh gemini uh moving forward
yeah honestly i mean i don't think that
we would be anywhere close to where we
are without gemini
and specifically cameron and tyler you
never really know what's gonna happen
after an acquisition you know everyone
everyone says things
it's it's kind of like that old saying
where during a job interview it's like
you lie to them they lie to you
and then like everyone and then you sign
the papers and like it's all done with
so we didn't really know when we started
if they would actually give us autonomy
and actually like
uh really sort of carve out the space
for nifty gateway to operate
but they they completely followed
through and uh
they really like they really set up the
environment perfectly
for for nifty gateway to succeed so i i
think they deserve a ton of credit
not only that but they they contributed
in a lot of very specific hands-on
ways you know recruiting people to
create on the platform they were huge in
that
they they had a lot of you know direct
impact on the product and the strategy
the company
um he hires they were enormous so
they've really been like enormously
influential
and yeah i think i i think it was sort
of like a
genuinely visionary move and then they
executed perfectly
because they they basically let nipple
gateway grow on its own
and and you know grow to be the product
that it is today
um which yeah i i really think they
deserve a ton of credit
and i'm really happy to be working with
them they've been fantastic partners
well they speak uh just as highly of a
views so
it was a a marriage made to happen and
uh obviously you both all being twins
still uh uh is one of the craziest
freakiest things in the world
but uh but it works yeah that's still
that's still what people love to talk
about
i'm like we're more than just twins you
know we're people
[Laughter]
well i think what isn't uh is not weird
is twins the weird part is
twins acquiring twins and but people
always want to know and they
you know folks who have uh who know that
i've had you on podcast before
always asking me like do you think that
that makes them like each other more is
because like they're like twins and i
was like i don't think they've probably
thought about it at
all if not maybe maybe they had one
conversation once like oh you guys are
twins too okay cool and like then they
went and got to work but
yeah yeah it was much more like that i
mean twins are just regular people
you know it's it's not that different
than having a brother
it's you know it's like it's a it's a
pretty similar
concept we'll we'll start the uh the
twitter campaign for twins or people too
and uh and hopefully get you guys some
uh some credibility there
uh awesome man listen what uh i want you
to leave everyone with uh kind of your
pitch
to uh artists i know that that's uh
where your heart lies and the rest of
the team
uh just what's your pitch uh if
somebody's thinking about doing a
dropbox you can do it on nifty gateway
yeah honestly i think the pitch is
navigating the nft world is really
difficult
um you know careers are volatile it can
be really hard to make the right
decisions
you know you really you need someone
with the experience and you need someone
who's going to be a trusted partner
that's really our goal fully one-third
of the company is dedicated to
artist relations like those are people
who just spend all day long working with
artists helping them come up with
new releases um and
yeah that's really like nifty gateway is
is gonna be a true partner to you
in your career so that's my pitch to
artists
i uh i think it's a good product good
people
and hopefully good times so listen man
thank you so much for doing this i
always enjoy talking to you
uh hopefully we will get you guys uh
digital museums many many more artists
and next time we talk it won't be 140
million in monthly sales it'll be a
billion
so keep at it and we'll do it again
and we'll have a thousand engineers so
that all billion in sales are
executed flawlessly
awesome all right thanks so much for
doing this thanks bob